Picture this.  You sit down in front of
a new movie.
Or you turn on the radio in the car.
What is your brain doing?
Well, a lot of things, hopefully.
But your brain is also working to make sense
of whatever media you encounter.
A flicker of pattern recognition and you realize
this new movie has a reference to Citizen Kane.
A stab of memory, and you’re singing the
hook of that song.
All. Day. Long.
For every conscious reaction and response you
have to media, your brain is also subconsciously
reacting and responding.
Our brains do plenty of things automatically.
They tell our lungs to breathe and our heart
to beat.
And while a lot of these automatic functions
are pretty great, there are a few that aren’t. –
especially when it comes to media.
So today we look at how our minds react to
media.
You wanna be media literate?
Well here's a list of the worst impulses inside
your brain that you're going to have to overcome.
This is your brain on media.
[Theme Song]
When was the last time you thought about tying
your shoes?
Like, really had to think about it?
Maybe not since you learned how, right?
That’s because your brain has automated
the process.
It’s muscle memory.
Our brains are pretty good at automating routine
stuff.
They do this to reduce the cognitive load,
or the amount of time and attention needed
to finish a task.
Imagine your brain is like a computer – it
only has so much RAM to use at any moment.
To make the best use of that processing power,
the brain relies on schema.
A schema is a thought pattern, a way the brain
understands a task, the desired outcomes of
that task, and the strategy for getting there.
If you have a routine, any routine, you have
a schema to work through it.
What about news gathering?
Maybe before you even open your eyes in
the morning you reach for your phone to scroll
through the latest headlines on Twitter.
Or maybe you turn the TV on while you cook
and listen to the news.
Or maybe you just hope someone will have
a copy of today’s paper on the bus so you can
read it when they’re done.
With any news habit, your brain is not only
automating you picking up your phone in the
morning or turning on the TV.
It’s also automating how you make sense
of information in that app or article.
All that efficiency in our brains, which is ideal for
brushing your teeth or opening a door, is not ideal for
parsing through complex or new information.
Our brains are basically designed to take
shortcuts.
And shortcuts are bad for business when
we’re trying to do the hard work of navigating
the media landscape.
So are there other parts of the brain that
protect us from this?
Whoo-boy, it’s not even close.
Bad news my friends:
It’s exactly the opposite.
The human brain is a mysterious thing.
We can remember what we did one day 12 years
ago, but not remember what we had for breakfast.
We’ll recall ungodly amounts of song lyrics
but can never remember what that one actor’s
name is. (It’s Bill Paxton)
We’ll be totally exhausted, but when our head hits the
pillow, suddenly we want to recap every embarrassing
thing we’ve done since second grade.
But for all its wacky inconsistencies, one thing
the brain does really well is complete a picture.
When we’re talking about visual perception – you
see a bunch of dots in the shape of a panda, and you
think “panda” – that’s called the Law of Closure.
As we move through the media environment,
we’re constantly trying to form this type of closure.
And our brains don’t do this objectively.
Each time we take a bit of info and complete
the picture, we’re using prior life experiences
and knowledge.
So, for instance, when you read a headline like
“DiCaprio and Winslet recreate epic scene from Titanic,”
you’d use prior knowledge to fill in the gaps.
You know Frank DiCaprio and Maggie Winslet
didn’t star in that film, so it must be referencing
Leonardo DiCaprio and Kate Winslet.
It’s like the brain’s version of when Google
knows you’re searching for “how to know your
cat loves you” just from the letter H.
No? Is that...is that just me?
This inherent desire to connect the dots, to see
the whole instead of its parts – is exactly what
makes humans vulnerable to misinformation.
Consider another unhelpful brain reflex: false
memory.
Sometimes when we can’t exactly recall the
details of an event, our brain will just fill in the
blanks with something plausible.
For instance, say you witnessed a robbery.
The police show up and ask you, “What color
shirt was the robber wearing?”
It happened so fast you think, huh I’m not
quite sure.
And another witness says, “I think it was
purple.”
And suddenly maybe you remember the robber
was wearing a purple shirt.
It’s not that you are trying to lie.
It’s more like your brain thinks, “yeah, that
sounds about right,” and the line between memory
and imagination is just too thin to notice.
The trouble with a false memory, especially when it
comes to misinformation and “fake news,” is it’s much
easier to create a memory than it is to change one.
So when a Facebook page built to spread fake news
sends a lie out into the world, readers are more likely to
remember that lie than to update their memory of it later.
Even when they have the right info.
Another time-saver the brain uses is hunting
for information we already believe to be true.
This is called confirmation bias, and it’s
a huge problem.
Let’s jump into the Thought Bubble to check
it out.
Each and every one of us wakes up in the morning
biased.
Biased toward early mornings or late nights,
biased towards conservatism or liberalism,
biased towards reading news or watching it
on TV.
Our life’s worth of experiences shape us to
prefer, understand, and believe certain things.
When we’re confronted with an avalanche of
information, which is difficult to wade through, we seek
out things we already prefer, understand, and believe.
It’s just easier, cognitively and emotionally,
to only deal with things we already like.
This means that if we’re presented with
a message that aligns with or confirms our
biases, we’re extra likely to believe it.
On the other hand, if that message opposes
our biases, we’re extra likely to think it’s false.
It also means that if you and I both experience
the same media, we could take away completely
different meanings.
Take this Washington Post article from October
2017, for example.
“Clinton campaign, DNC paid for research
that led to Russia dossier”
It says that Hillary Clinton’s presidential campaign
and the Democratic National Committee paid for
research into Donald Trump’s campaign.
This dossier was very controversial when it
was revealed in 2016.
Many Clinton supporters and liberal Americans
believed the dossier was proof of Trump’s
collusion with a foreign power.
Many Trump supporters and conservative Americans
believed it was proof that the Democratic party was
trying to take down the Republican candidate.
Now, if you already have a Democratic bias you
might think, “Wow, the dossier must have been legit.
Why would the Democratic party spend time
and money on a phony story?”
And If you have a Republican bias, you
could conclude the opposite:
“Wow, the dossier must have been phony the whole
time, if it was financed by the Democratic party.”
This means that a piece of information can do
the same thing for different people: communicate,
simply, what you already believe is true is true.
Thanks, Thought Bubble.
Social media presents an extra obstacle: most
platforms, like Facebook, Twitter, and Instagram,
are built to reward confirmation bias.
Those companies want you in their apps as
long as possible, so their algorithms are tuned
to keep showing you stuff you like.
Which would be fine, if 38% of U.S. adults
didn’t rely on them for news.
Which brings us to another brain time-saver:
information satisficing – a bizarre combo
of “satisfying” and “sufficing.”
Sometimes when we’re busy or not really that
concerned with hunting down the right answer, we’ll
accept whatever answer’s laid out in front of us.
Say, your second-favorite celeb couple breaks
up.
They won’t talk to the press about it, but
a tabloid at the grocery store says he cheated
with the nanny. Scandalous!
You think that sounds plausible, and since this info
isn’t life-or-death important, this answer suffices.
Searching through old interviews to look for
clues of a slowly dissolving romance –
we’ve all got things to do, like figure out whether
our cat loves us.
Age-old tabloid tales like cheating with the
nanny prey on another aspect of our brain’s
desire to complete the picture.
We love stories.
Really, we love stories.
If it’s simple, easy to understand, and fills
in the gaps for us, we are ready to believe.
But the human instinct for storytelling is
straight up dangerous to media literacy.
Stories are sense-making tools; they help
us understand the world around us.
So when something is complex or difficult to understand
and the media turns it into a familiar narrative for us, we
welcome it with wide, open arms – even if it’s false.
To sum up, your brain on media is prone to
taking shortcuts and filling in the blanks of a
story whenever, and however, it can.
What’s worse, publishers, advertisers, and
tech companies know all of these tricks, too!
They use them against us all the time to hold
(or steal) our attention.
If you’ve absolutely never fallen prey to
fake news or some other kind of misinformation
– well congratulations.
But for the rest of us, it’s not always
easy to spot our brain’s thought patterns
at work, let alone break them.
That’s where strong critical thinking skills
come in, and the shared responsibility of doing
this work together, as a society.
The more we acknowledge our biases and thought
patterns, the better we get at smashing through
them to find the truth.
We’ll continue that hard work together on
the next episode of Crash Course: Media Literacy.
For now, I’m Jay Smooth.
See you next week!
Crash Course Media Literacy is filmed in the
Dr. Cheryl C. Kinney Studio in Missoula, MT.
It’s made with the help of all of these nice
people, and our animation team is Thought Cafe.
Crash Course is a Complexly production.
If you wanna keep imagining the world complexly
with us check out some of our other channels,
like The Financial Diet, SciShow Space, and
Mental Floss.
If you'd like to keep Crash Course free for
everyone, forever, you can support the series
at Patreon,
a crowdfunding platform that allows
you to support the content you love.
Thank you to all of our patrons for making
Crash Course possible with their continued
support.